没有人值得我们拿自己的工作去冒险，
放弃自己的前途去冒险。
你如果今天告诉我，
你说龙飞姐，
我就算在他的城市的话，
我随便考，
我也能再考一个好工作，
那你可以考虑，
但如果说自己没有这个能力的话，
你能保住现在的工作就是放在第一位了。
我是否就是该把这段关系当做我长期发展的方向来看待，
我说一下我跟我对象吧，
然后我是20多岁，
在县城的乡镇编制，
因为正在读大学，
我爸爸在上班，
妈妈在家是工作的，
家里呢给了我一套县城的房子和一辆车，
我对象是比我大三岁，
然后他跟我一个县城的，
他爸妈在县城里有一套贷款房，
他自己在省会城市工作，
无房无车，
他自己是说家里的没法给到助力了，
而且他现在目前还是有助学贷款贷款，
然后他也是刚出来工作，
他个人呢是在省会的国企上班，
我俩现在是异地，
他就说他和他家里控制于海棠，
他不太爱回，
就不怎么回县城，
回家见我，
他也不会回家，
他自己会找一个酒店住，
这是一个问题，
就是异地，
我再怎么调动也不可能调到他的城市去，
我调动最多就是县城的调动问题，
二就是我和他就是聊过以后结婚的事儿，
然后他当时就是表示没有想过，
就没有细想过。
我为什么跟他聊这个事，
是因为我觉得县城的婚恋市场就那么大，
然后我现在年龄也是不处于比较优势吧，
所以我就不想拖，
当时我就说如果他没有想那么多。
说我俩就结束了，
就算了，
又想了一下，
他又能给到我答复，
给到我一个满意的答复吧，
说是自己攒攒钱，
然后我们又继续谈下去了，
至今我都非常的就处于这段关系当中，
一直都是比较间接性的焦虑当中，
就是有时候想的就很多，
但是分开的又有一点不太舍得，
想的多是你对自己负责任，
姑娘你非常严肃认真的来考虑这个异地的问题，
暂时又没有办法解决掉这个问题就挺好的，
有很多女孩子她不考虑这个，
他恋爱老上头的时候就管他异不异地的，
他管她远不远嫁的，
他不考虑这个，
我感觉你能考虑这个就很棒啊。
但是我应该就是你现在才二十几岁，
正是好意清好找对象的年纪，
应该果断一点，
就是应该果断一点是吗？
当然了，
首先自己能挣钱，
自己的工作是排在第一位的，
永远没有人值得我们拿自己的工作去冒险，
放弃自己的前途去冒险，
你如果今天告诉我，
你说龙飞姐，
我就算在他的城市的话，
我随便考我也能再考一个好工作，
那你可以考虑，
但如果说自己没有这个能力的话，
你能保住现在的工作就是放在第一位了，
他就是我也还是顺着我的吧，
然后我感觉你顺着你那很正常的朋友来，
我们作为一个已婚的有了娃的中年女性来告诉你啊，
基本上吧，
刚开始的时候都是顺着你，
她不顺着你的话，
她没法儿处你，
没法儿交付真心，
交付身。
体交付，
这些都会顺着你，
嗯，
但是真正到过日子的时候，
女人一定要有实力，
一定要有实力，
一定要自己能挣钱，
一定要自己有底气，
一定要自己能够任何时候有可以选择的这样一个空间小巷，
人家有一个阶段，
我就特别能共情，
那个黄玲，
就是他女儿小婷，
想放弃现在的工作，
去那个男方那儿，
动哲那边去，
他就特别反对。
他就以他的人生经历来看，
他说他之所以还能保住小婷，
保住图南他们的学习条件，
就是因为他自己有一份工作，
如果他要是没有那份工作的话，
以图南的爸爸，
小婷的爸爸那尿性的话，
那估计图南和小婷都不会有任何的出息，
就什么事儿都得对他的原生家庭进行一个牺牲。
我当时就特别能共情那个黄玲那一点，
我现在对于所有的未婚的女孩子，
我还是这样，
就自己能挣钱，
自己能真金白银的赚回来，
这个选择权才是硬道理，
后面就是不大可能就是结婚姻之类的是吧，
反正你俩要么有一个人，
他本事很强，
他来你这儿也能考个工作哦，
好好好，
姑娘，
这话你真的一定要听进去啊，
任何时候都是工作排在第一位的，
工作一定是排在第一位的，
好的，
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
谢谢老拜拜，
你看宋莹你要这一辈子啊，
坦率的说啊，
你要是遇到宋莹老公那样的男的的话啊，
有这个福气，
但即便是你遇到宋莹老公。
放的男的的话，
你看宋莹什么时候放弃过挣钱，
就算她说跟着她老公南下了，
她有放弃挣钱吗？
人家自己哪怕是在家里就做点包子，
做点饺子，
做点儿什么小吃食，
人家也一直在挣钱，
是不是这意思？
现实生活中有没有那种说自己不挣钱，
夫妻关系经营的很好，
国家关系经营的好的人呢？
有可能说1000个人里面有一个就1‰，
1000个人里面有一个，
但是你要问龙飞姐，
龙飞姐你有这个本事，
在你不挣钱的时候，
你能经营好这个社会关系吗？
你能经营好夫妻关系，
你能经营好跟公婆的关系吗？
坦率的说，
我没有这个本事，
我相信我的姐妹当中大多数人也没有这个本事，
在我们不挣钱的时候去经营好这些关系，
所以就不要冒这个风险，
龙菲姐没钱的时候也不能经营好感情了，
经营不好我会自卑，
又自卑又是高的自尊，
人就很拧巴，
你知道吧，
记得点赞关注哦。